Film Courage: Why do you love making mistakes?
Pedro Correa, Actor/Filmmaker: I
think mistakes make amazing stories
if I’m ever in a horrible place or
I made a huge mistake i'll instantly
just grasp for some comedy of the moment
because you might as well use it I think I
think a lot of drama too comes from laughing about
mistakes I think I think good log lines come from
laughing about mistakes my favorite like log
lines from movies are ones where you have the
the air blow through your nose you read it you
go so I love mistakes I try to embrace them
well I think we have a quote here and sorry
to quote you I know it's kind of it's kind
of weird but okay here here we go so we have a
quote here I learned that when I throw myself
into the fire and if I don't feel the heat
I've failed comfort is the death of progress
that's pretty brilliant wow I like that I sound
like a dictator no well okay but I mean get what
you're talking about because if you if you're just
comfortable all the time you're not growing you're
not doing anything you're kind of staying stagnant
can you give us examples of how you've made
yourself either purposely uncomfortable or life
has thrown you into those circumstances yeah um
I feel like this probably came from moving
around in my life a lot like moving to
different countries and locations and schools
all the time it started as schools then it was
cities and countries and then careers at one
point I wanted to be approached snowboarder
and then I moved to the desert with my mom and I
was like well so much for that but I think moving
around a lot teaches you to reinvent yourself
teaches you makes you really look at yourself
you get this opportunity to redefine every part
of you really and I think that has taught me
that that can be a very powerful thing with
art too I think like I mentioned playing music
a little bit that's been a good outlet for me to
come back to the movies I make and really look at
them in a different way and that goes with acting
it goes with writing it goes to producing it goes
with directing editing and that's why I love
doing all those things because they all inform
each other and when you're struggling with one you
can always focus on another one that can inform
what you were struggling with so if there's
any opportunity to throw yourself in the fire
I mean you can't get burnt so you got to be
careful and you got to have people around
you tell you to chill out or or just have a
great team of people you can collaborate with
but I think it's a healthy thing for an artist how
many times were you the new kid in class oh man
it'd be interesting to count
all right one two three
four five six seven to man I was probably the
new kid in class like seven times before I like
graduated high school and
by class I mean like school
or maybe more I think like nine maybe actually
now that I think of it but I always thought there
was like a problem with me like when I was going
to high school specifically but I mean even from
elementary school I remember telling my mom I was
like I think I'm dyslexic I think I'm dyslexic uh
i guess there's like tests for it or the teachers
would like comment on what they think about it
they just send me like a counselor like no you're
not there's nothing wrong with you and I was like
dang it like there's nothing wrong with me and
then I just realized I don't like school and
school had no no outlet for me to learn what
I love doing the only thing I ever found
that had information that I really grasped onto
and took and used in my real life is YouTube
like when I was like 11 or something I think
YouTube just became a thing back then and
and that's how I learned how to edit and and that
I started watching little scenes of movies like
bootleg uploaded to YouTube and i'd watch that and
that was where I learned everything I've even seen
you guys videos by the way I didn't even mention
this but I watched film a few film courage videos
in pre-production of My Dead Dad [co-written and
directed by Fabio Frey] oh wow and that that's
amazing to me that's amazing that you can be a kid
in the Middle East and no not a single filmmaker
and yet know all the filmmakers and take something
from that wow very cool well thank you that's
that's pretty cool I was wondering though if that
actually helps you that uncomfortable it's always
uncomfortable going to a new school or having
to go to high school and you're the freshman and
you don't know anyone but if you've done that
let's say more than five times I wonder if that's
actually helped you with auditions because how
uncomfortable is it to go into a room with a bunch
of other people reading sides and they're all up
for the same part and oh hey how's it going and
but everybody's there for they're your competition
and then but you've been through that I just
thought that was interesting maybe it's helpful
yeah now that is interesting I definitely think
moving schools has helped me in many facets of
my life I like to think semi-cognizant and human
communication I said that like a robot so maybe
not but moving schools is definitely kind of like
auditioning for different groups of people and and
even if you've never moved into school like moved
moved into high school from middle
school like that's a different
group of people instantly and I think I think
the greatest thing I ever learned in school was
just how to communicate and watch people and I
think by moving so many times that definitely
helps with that absolutely and and maybe
there's like a an aspect of moving too
where especially moving different countries you're
kind of the weird kid already just by like default
I mean it's funny but like moving to Peru for
example I'm Peruvian but I don't look Peruvian so
being the white kid there is is technically
the minority if you can say that
in Peru so it instantly gave me a different
perspective that I would have never gotten
just living in Seattle and I think because
of that I was okay with being a little
weird or myself really and the older I get and
the more I do this movie making stuff is that I
realize that's the only thing you really have to
offer like your weirdness your you so even now
I've had friends of friends or
friends of girls I was dating be like
you're weird dude and I used to be like and now
I'm kind of like nice that's good okay I'm being
myself like I like that and maybe I'm leaning into
it too much now but it's I just feel like you're
getting so many more interesting conversations and
and come up with movie ideas and and and you don't
start molding yourself this thing that you're not
and then when you make movies then you're making
movies that aren't you and that's not authentic
and everyone can pick up on that so right
no I love that all right but what about the
horrible word of sell out what what does that
conjure up because I know a lot of people that
are very authentic and and revel sort of relish in
their weirdness for lack of a better term I think
they're afraid of the word sellout because then
that means being sort of this corporate thing but
sometimes you have to be a sellout I think yeah I
I think being a sellout is doing something I
think being a seller I was getting is getting
behind something that you don't believe in like
on a on a deeper level what I mean I mean like
I’ve done plenty of jobs that I am like about but
at the time it was right for me to do because I
needed to learn certain things and it was just
another challenge really so I think you get
you can be more fortunate the longer you stick
around in this business and you can choose the
skirt around sell out feeling things a little bit
more but I don't really it's funny I haven't heard
that word in forever because like I think I'm
dating myself no and it's also just because like
I think I'm working with with more pros these
days what I mean who who kind of understand like
hey like this is not a genre or a thing that
I'm like naturally drawn to but what I could
really make it better because I see it this
way and and it's a creative challenge almost
and also I have a family and kids and a mortgage
but but once you start I think once you start
bringing that energy back into your own stuff
that is supposed to be the passion project kind of
movies or whatever it may be that's
where you're starting to get into trouble
like I've even had conversations or brainstorming
sessions with collaborators of mine who we've come
up with an idea and we're like oh that's cool and
oh that would work really well right now because
of this or like people would like that and then
we're like hold on hold on like do we like that no
never mind so it really depends on the
context I feel like the word sellout
to me did that come up at all with your
first feature film my dad dad where there
were something where you're like what that would
have been that'd be too corporate or whatever I am
oh you did okay no absolutely absolutely and
making your first feature is like can be hell
and it's like a miracle that like you get through
it so you do sometimes have to compromise on small
things and and you really have to put your foot
down at other times and be like this is where it
stops like we're maintaining this vision like we
want to shoot with two cameras like that's what
we're going to do or or we're not going to make
this we're not going to cater to like a tv network
to to change the title or whatever like people
either hated the title or love the title and maybe
talk to me in eight months when the movies are
public you'll be like it wasn't called My Dead Dad
but but I will say that those are one of those
things I was really insistent at least keeping
it through through the festival run of being like
no this is like the title like it's I some people
hate it some people love it everyone definitely
double takes at it and it's representative of
the movie of course we wanted to shoot on
film originally like that is a okay that's I
guess a compromise we made we shot on two digital
cameras but but we didn't compromise on our color
to make it look like film so it's the ebb and
flow for sure if I saw that title on Netflix
in in suggested I would definitely click on it
just to see what the log line was no so it does
work I hope so for me at least but so people
thought maybe it was too off-putting the title
there was there was times where people were
like well so it's such a personal title to where
depending on how you feel about the world or your
parents you're going to get a different reaction
because My Dead Dad movie some people
have been like oh my god that's so dark or
whatever and other people have been like so
it's like a comedy or yeah and I kind of love
it because it describes our movie pretty well
where it's got some heavy moments but it's also
got some moments where you're like what like
two guys hanging out talking about like uh
you just got to watch the movie right but funny
moments guys being guys yes guys being guys
yeah and that's another one too there was
a lot of a lot of pages in the script where
some of it just came from real life conversations
just conversations that you would have alone with
your close friends and we got notes on certain
stuff and we just kept them the great thing about
like shooting is that there's always the editing
of it and you get to rewrite everything anyway
so when anyone ever gives you such like
a do or die script note I'm just like
no like if you believe in it just keep it in like
you you can always decide later that's the beauty
and the difference between like doing something
live and shooting and cutting it and it's a whole
process so stay true to your script all right
and don't worry women are just as bad pretend
Yes I've eavesdropped yes there
you go ex-girlfriend conversation.
Do you grow from mistakes?